xbox on snap hey guys it's chris waters
here with John McGuinness Xbox nap can
you tell that we're playing a Kinect
game at guys are real hearted trolling
me yes that's right multiple players are
taken haha hang on the titanfall
campaign today seriously Xbox unsnap oh
my god I put out a call on Twitter this
morning uh to see if any any of you
wanted to join and yet her for 20
answered the call yet her say hello to
the fine folks haha i think yet her has
perished yeah did you tell by that harsh
grunt and I needed to get get away hey
what's the deal with these flying drones
jobbers there I just shot one actually
yeah I've been shooting them but I don't
actually seem to be getting gonna you
can jump on them if you're uh you can
jump on them you can jump on them in I
like your ideas are ah I'd like to
subscribe to your newsletter hey it's
called the Saskatchewan weekly oh yeah
yeah why did you tell me that I could
jump on these drones cuz it's all I want
to do now I'm gonna jump on these drone
I'm gonna find a rooftop and then I'm
gonna jump on these jerks if it doesn't
work I'm gonna goblet stupid but alright
I'll get back oh good my team won
despite my completely radiations oh let
me jump on ya oh a pallod i call this
part don't let your enemies return to
their families bucket bucket you better
xbox recorded at the s out of that s
I'm trying not to swear on this show
yeah you're doing a great job yeah we
drop multiple f-bombs not two seconds
ago yeah but they're like cool f-bombs
like casual kind of cool that moms like
like Robert De Niro would do not those
like anger f-bombs not really offensive
no I'm not talking like some Denis Leary
type of jazz it's hard to make heads or
tails of what's going on but her related
note Sean gets very confused when
watching transformers movie oh my god
tell me about it when the big
transformer guy comes up and he's all
like Oh Optimus Prime what does that
even mean I haven't Optimus Prime what
does that even mean yeah nice you know
real nice it's maybe using a metaphor
definitely a metaphor metaphor for I'm i
think that's not off on his prime I'm
gonna punch you because I'm a robot you
are also robot and this is how robots
speak to each other with punches with
punches because we are not oh oh yeah
you're dead I'm not getting on your ship
jerk oh this dude's trying to shoo me
know at least I denied somebody the
chance to reunite with her family oh I
got to 11
whoa the imc is trying to be all nah you
can't have it and the militias like oh I
know we really want to go you ready for
this Chris yeah koplow ha eat it oh no
come back dragon monster you're so
majestic and I love onion team into them
I will take care of it you express your
love by head shopping thing yes me out
so what up jerk I would be like a rocket
salvo straight to your robot testes
ones of God is saying yeah and they said
something about shoot that robot in the
testicles with your Rockets elbow for
extra story reasons ah so much rich
narrative tapestry watch me shoot this
dragon in the butt oh it exploded check
this [ __ ] out Oh get it gone oh he got
away nuts I'm gonna rock it salvo all
these stupid dragons come on why would
you get killed ah well let's I did not
run into this big room that is on fire
and you do a thing to it the other day I
just died from scripted campaign events
I absolutely did I didn't die once that
whole match up top Jim Godfrey says my
ex-wife had a Titan hole that's why
she's my ex-wife wow that is rude and I
don't know why I just read that on there
do they intend to destroy the repulsive
towers of the heart of this facility the
militia will do anything to destroy
these towers if we lose there's nothing
to protect this place from the elements
let's go this is a serious military
briefing we have to kill these Titans
and then we can kill the dinosaur okay
all right I'm shooting it I'm shooting
it where are you it's not dying though I
think that they are just literally just
window dressing we're gonna try to
target this dinosaur over here oh yeah
ders auto Titan just got dead I don't
think this is gonna happen no not seen
any hit markers wow that rocket barrages
but freaks out dinosaur the third Chris
pound plated fist pump yeah
all right oh good you are super on fire
by the way really wow yeah look at that
head come off nice damn Wow I am NOT oh
here we go I mean got it good so what I
lying wait yeah I'm gonna hide there's a
Titan coming at your grill whoa he found
my secret hiding spot worry he'll be
dead in like two seconds oh yeah Shh I
just punched him and whoa-ho you're not
going huh you just know and he's
flattered against the invisible wall at
the edge of the environment yeah I'm
sorry pilot do you think you're gonna
hit me what do you take us for because
I'm not super cool on Titan dudes ah oh
oh wait doesn't that guy you know he got
that is he on you I'll make sure that
you were a big sublet step of it oh yeah
oh look make it all sorry we're shooting
to the ship whatever our to really
determine I littlest of them the chance
to go home all right I think that we
saved ourselves from dinosaurs yeah we
did that would happen no deaths again
that was awful that's two matches in a
row here what i like to call a low
impact player all right yet her what are
what are some pro tips for this next
match we're about to get ourselves into
uh usually I make a beeline for see
right off the bat you need to any the
hardpoint that's closest to the enemy
yep because more often than not they'll
take it and run from it see people who
are sneaky tacking oh that was a little
ghost on ghost but kick sorry I misled
you guys about that but kick I was gonna
do with them oh I just punched the Titan
in the butt
Oh dead I don't know you need to get
haha lightning gun get Jed yeah that's
what people say that your new slogan get
dead oh oh not today jerkstore that dude
thought he could rodeo me yeah give me
here we go you missed I'm right over
here come on wait hold on yeah up onto
me get on this [ __ ] we're gonna have a
good time know where it is you're dead
now bad man you have been murder eyes
and now we are have taught someone by
accident that's what's called being a
Titan I love it when that happens shout
out to yet are 420 for being the first
community member to join us an online
multiplayer for multiple players here
folks if you want to join in on future
multiple players online play
opportunities go ahead and follow me at
CT waters on twitter that's where i'll
put out the call for multiple players
allies in the coming weeks not sure
we're playing next week but i'm sure
it'll be a real barn burner we'll be
giving away copies of titanfall during
our 4pm titanfall stream where we're
going to have pro gamers talking about
titanfall about the full release etc if
you guys watched our discussions
previously for the beta you're going to
want to check that out and of course at
2pm it's the lobby Daniel I are going to
be playing we're going to have dark
souls 2 on there we're going to have a
crawl which is a really manic row co-op
competitive roguelike thing that looks
awesome and also jeff gerstmann from
giant bomb is going to be joining us to
talk about titanfall so that's at 2pm
another live stream at for opportunities
to win games abound so hopefully we'll
see you then and you can see this guy
tomorrow at 11am 11am sure the Sean
method thanks so much for coming and
watching we'll see you next time